ich bin in der Sache der Meinung dass es
richtig ist diese beiden Chipfabriken in
Magdeburg und in Dresden anzusiedeln wir
brauchen hier eine
strategische Unabhängigkeit Europas in
einer ganz wesentlichen Industrie über
die wir zur Zeit nicht verfü und das
müssen wir eben leider unter den
gegebenen Umständen machen damit wir
hier diese Prozesse in Europa auch
besser eigenständig und souveräner äh äh
führen könen undhäig von China
Unabhängigkeit auch von Taiwan taiwan
ist mit TSMC ja der größte chipersteller
der Welt und deswegen setze ich mich
sehr dafür ein dass wir das hinbekommen
das geht auch aus dem laufenden Haushalt
zu finanzieren für diese Chipfabrik in
Magdeburg sind zwei Drittel bereits im
Haushalt buüdgetiert da fehlen jetzt
noch 2,8 Milliarden dafür braucht man
nicht die Schuldenbremse zu lösen also
wir können das machen aus dem laufenden
Budget